we could be seeing some more growth on
the Las Vegas Strip the Las Vegas
Convention Center has sold 10 acres of
land so here it is it's right across
from Slots of Fun and Circus Circus and
next to Fountain Blue Mary Jane belyaza
has more in the deal and what it could
mean for our growing City
turn onto the North End of the strip and
you'll notice a fresh face of new
buildings from Resorts World to Fountain
Blue you can expect the growth to
continue as the Las Vegas Convention and
visitors authorities wrapping up a deal
to sell a portion of their land on Elvis
Presley and Las Vegas Boulevard formerly
where the Riviera Hotel and Casino used
to sit Lori Nelson craft senior vice
president of communications for the
convention center says they sold the
land for 120 million to Chilean real
estate investor Claudio Fisher when the
lvcva purchased the Riviera it was
always with knowing that it would be put
towards the expansion of the Las Vegas
Convention Center it was always
contemplated that way and while we used
some of the land from the Riviera we
were able to relocate the West Hall
project in a more desirable location to
the campus which really allowed us to
have 10 extra Acres proceeds from the
sale will go towards the convention
center 600 million renovation plan it's
all to help accommodate the thousands of
visitors that come through their doors
and into Las Vegas not only do we have
our West Hall expansion but Resorts
World has debuted Fountain Blue is well
on its way to opening next year the
Sahara has been reimagined with new
owners so the whole North End of the
strip has really just changed and
morphed beautifully over the past few
years Jen and Bob Woods visiting from
Minnesota are curious to see what will
become of the new land it's like every
time you come out here there's gonna be
something new and exciting to check out
tourist Jan Kent and Sherry Carlson say
new development gives them a reason to
keep coming back I like to see growth in
this city you know it's good that means
the economy is booming and
yeah we want to see that again yeah yeah
people out you know from the strip Mary
Jane beliesza 8 News Now